[Musique]
bonjour Thérèse Baif merci de nous
accueillir chez vous dans votre intimité
pour une interview tout en confidence
bonjour à vous alors à 92 ans vous êtes
une femme active encore et toujours
comment devient-on Thérèse Baillif qui
est Thérèse Bailly
pour moi c'est quelqu'un de très simple
quelqu'un qui
a connu comme tout le monde et des bas
dans sa vie
et qui et qui a
profité un petit peu de leçons de la vie
donc je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui
qui a décidé un jour de continuer à
avancer envers et contre tout maintenant
pour aller où je ne sais pas mais
l'essentiel c'était surtout d'être en
activité et justement quand on fait des
recherches sur vous on apprend que vous
n'avez jamais conçu votre vie sans
travail pourtant à l'époque c'était pas
la norme comment vous êtes parvenu à
vous émanciper un peu des règles de
cette société en fait moi vous savez je
suis la campagne
mon père était agriculteur et tenir en
même temps un commerce nous étions une
famille nombreuse et c'est vrai que à la
campagne c'était les avirons à l'époque
c'était dans les années 1930 quand même
je suis né en 1930 les filles étaient
destinées à se marier
et dans le village et à faire des
enfants et à s'occuper de leur famille
et c'est vrai que moi j'ai un père qui
qui m'a donné l'exemple du travail et on
avait tous chacun notre petit travail
chacun avait son il y a un qui arrosé le
jardin
était enfant chacun avait sa petite
tâche domestique j'ai toujours eu
l'habitude d'être en action en activité
mon père a décidé lui que que ses
enfants s'il n'avait rien d'autre à leur
donner qu'il pouvait au moins donner la
connaissance et donc
je suis parti je suis parti des
adhérents donc je suis allée chercher du
boulot tout de suite j'ai trouvé du
travail tout de suite j'ai commencé
tâtonner et puis j'ai passé des concours
des examens et je suis arrivée un petit
peu à ce qu'il y a m'a fait ma carrière
où j'étais ma carrière à loin d'être à
l'époque c'était les Eaux et Forêts et
donc j'ai commencé à l'ONF en tant que
en tant qu'employé de bureau et
justement vous avez reçu un certain
nombre de décorations officiers de
l'ordre national du Mérite chevalier de
la Légion d'Honneur votre prix
départemental du Mérite notamment et
aussi officier du Mérite agricole alors
vous nous avez dit vous allez travailler
au Zoé forêt un milieu d'hommes on peut
dire à l'époque et exactement exactement
en fait quand je suis arrivé
aux forêt il n'y avait pratiquement que
des hommes il y avait que quelques
femmes comme moi quand je suis arrivée
il devait y avoir trois femmes dans tout
le service puis après j'ai passé des
examens tout doucement examens sur
examen donc je suis arrivée à être
le chat des services attaché
administratif principal l'échelle du
service c'était pour moi un travail très
très enrichissant et j'étais voilà
j'étais
contente de faire ce travail là parce
que ça me valorisait et mes patrons
étaient très contents aussi voilà alors
tout le monde connaît votre engagement
vis-à-vis du droit des femmes de façon
générale mais aussi vis-à-vis de la
lutte contre les violences
intrafamidales vous qui avez créé la
phare l'Association des femmes actuelles
de la Réunion puis le Séville le
collectif pour l'élimination des
violences centrales familiales qu'est-ce
qui a fait qu'un jour vous vous êtes dit
ça ça va être mon combat
vous savez à l'époque je voyais je
voyais les femmes je voyais les femmes
d'abord de mon village pour commencer et
c'était les femmes
elles avaient un destin et elles
acceptaient leur destin moi je ne je ne
sais pas si elle choisissait ce destin
où elle se voilà elle le subissait et
j'estimais que que
on ne nous permettait pas de nous de
nous exprimer réellement et moi-même
j'avais aussi envie de dire de
m'exprimer aussi de dire nous avons des
choses à faire et nous avons aussi une
place à prendre voilà c'était surtout
pour l'égalité des chances parce qu'on
s'apercevait que justement dans mon
service ONF les ingénieurs n'étaient que
des hommes et donc pour moi l'essentiel
c'était de faire en sorte que que qu'on
donne à chacun toutes les chances
possibles on imagine qu'avec une
vocation pareille votre engagement a pu
parfois empiéter sur votre vie
personnelle alors comment vous avez su
gérer votre rôle de de femmes d'épouse
de maman de femme engagées tout ça à la
fois c'est très compliqué
parce on se rend pas compte c'est après
qu'on se rencontre mais c'est vrai que
l'engagement c'est quelque chose qui
vous qui vous dévore
entièrement
parce que ce n'est pas un boulot que
vous faites de telle heure à telle heure
c'est un boulot que vous portez en
permanence
chaque jour sur 7
et donc c'est certain que
j'ai dû manquer dans les autres domaines
de ma vie mais quand vous avez fait un
choix vous assumez jusqu'au bout
je pense qu'il faut
il faut beaucoup d'amour
je pense pour essayer de concilier tout
merci beaucoup Thérèse Baillif